merci aussi non ctag aussi ne va pas au
japon
on va bien trouver quelqu'un qu'il
confie t-il venez visiter blocs rick est
tous assez pour des pour déchire ou
est-ce qu'il faut signer il peut dire
adieu à ta famille arrive tout le monde
dehors
on est ici bien venu à bout creek le
véritable blocry cq71 nouvelle maison
j'ai été amenée ici par erreur désormais
tu seras le numéro 4 6 3
je vais m'évader si tu as envie tu peux
venir avec moi
c'est lui vitaux je suis pas sûr d'y
arriver
quoi et si tu courais pour moi par
exemple on fonce je suis yeux ses yeux
ici je suis le big boss je vois tout
genre tout je re div de touches à 7 août
dernier a vraiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]